¿Estamos ante la reedición de la Guerra
Fría?
El conflicto de Ucrania o las Primaveras
Árabes han puesto de manifiesto que el
Gobierno de Vladimir Putin tiene
intereses muy distintos a los de Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea.
Esta diferencia se está materializando
en enfrentamientos violentos con muertos
y heridos. ¿Hasta qué punto está Europa a
las puertas de una gran guerra?
Hoy vamos a responder a esta pregunta y
lo vamos a hacer de la mano de Gema,
nuestra nueva colaboradora, que ha estado
viviendo en Lituania durante el último
año y colaborando, ni más ni menos, que
con la OTAN.
Hasta 2013 Ucrania era un país que no
daba mucho de qué hablar,
era una más de las antiguas repúblicas
soviéticas que no pertenecía ni a la
Unión Europea y a la OTAN y poca cosa
más.
Nadie predijo que un país aparentemente
tan tranquilo pudiera desencadenar todos
los quebraderos de cabeza que ha traído,
ni que fuera a ser uno de los países
que más han influido en la política
global en los últimos años. Desde
el estallido del euromaidá,n y su
consecuente guerra por los territorios
del este, y la anexión ilegal de Rusia
de Crimea, Ucrania ha sido el punto de
inflexión de un orden mundial
aparentemente tranquilo y de un bonito
período de paz para los Estados Unidos
y Rusia, aunque, ojo, las tensiones venían
de antes. - "Las guerras suelen empezar por un
pequeño incidente, señor embajador."
Ya desde la guerra de Georgia en 2008, La
Primavera Árabe y el contexto actual de
guerra en Siria, ambas superpotencias han
estado apoyando a los grupos opuestos.
Ahora bien y dejando atrás el contexto histórico,
si ya ha habido problemas antes entre la OTAN
y Rusia por conflictos en otros países
¿por qué el de Ucrania es tan importante?
Bien, la respuesta es en realidad
bastante sencilla: en el conflicto de
Ucrania es la primera que Rusia se ha
anexionado el territorio de un país
soberano
basándose en la existencia de minorías
rusas oprimidas; lo que hizo saltar las
alarmas en las repúblicas bálticas de
Estonia, Letonia y Lituania.
Estas antiguas repúblicas soviéticas,
ahora parte de la OTAN y de la Unión
Europea, cuentan con un porcentaje de
población étnicamente ruso muy elevado,
especialmente los casos de Estonia y
Letonia, en los que la población rusa
alcanza el 25%. Qué haya tanta gente de origen
ruso en el Báltico
no es casualidad, ni porque los rusos
tengan ahí sus casas de vacaciones, aunque
también, sino que nos remontamos a la
época de Stalin, que no era muy amigo de
todo aquello que no fuera ruso, es decir de
todas las minorías que vivían en las
repúblicas soviéticas. ¿Qué hizo Stalin?
Básicamente las deportaciones a
Siberia que todos conocemos, cogió
lituanos, estonios y letones y, ojo, gente
de los otros países también, y los
mandó a Siberia
mientras mandaba ciudadanos rusos a
habitar en estas zonas.
Esto, unido a la imposición del ruso
como lengua obligatoria y de la cultura
rusa sobre estos países, debería haber
homogeneizado a todas las repúblicas
soviéticas, pero, como la historia nos
demuestra, al final los nacionalismos
acabaron triunfando.
Repito que esto no pasa únicamente los
bálticos, sino que también se
encuentran con este problema
otros países como Georgia, Bielorrusia o
la misma Ucrania.
La diferencia con los bálticos es que al
ser miembros de la Unión Europea y la
OTAN podría esperarse de ellos una
cierta estabilidad, y es cierto,
así a priori las minorías rusas no son
ningún motivo de inestabilidad para
ellos en el corto plazo, pero están ahí,
en unos territorios que antaño fueron
invadidos por Rusia y a sabiendas de que
a la mínima de cambio Putin podría
utilizar a estos ciudadanos rusos como
excusa para básicamente cualquier cosa.
Así, a primera vista, cualquier
intervención rusa en países soberanos
y pertenecientes a la OTAN
parecería una locura ya que en tal caso
los países afectados tendrían derecho
a invocar el artículo 5 de la OTAN que
básicamente implicaría una tercera
guerra mundial. - "Las partes convienen en
que un ataque armado contra una o varias
de ellas, ocurrido en Europa o en
América del Norte, será considerado
como un ataque dirigido contra todas. En
consecuencia, convienen en que, si tal ataque se
produce, cada una de ellas asistirá a
la parte o partes atacadas tomando
individualmente y de acuerdo con las otras,
las medidas que juzgue necesario." Pero si
nos fijamos en cómo están actuando la
OTAN y Rusia en torno a esta zona,
la idea no parece tan descabellada.
Empezando por la OTAN y su cumbre el
pasado mes de julio en Varsovia, donde
los líderes de los 28 miembros, entre
otras cosas, se comprometieron a reforzar
la presencia militar en los bálticos y
en Polonia, al considerar a Rusia una
amenaza real.
En este contexto cabe decir que el
despliegue ya había empezado antes de
la cumbre, el pasado mes de junio con la
misión Anaconda. La misión Anaconda fue
la mayor maniobra militar desde la
Guerra Fría del siglo pasado. Un
movimiento, en mi opinión, innecesario en
un contexto de escalada de tensión como
es en el que nos encontramos y en el que,
además, aunque ya se sabía, se llegó a
la conclusión de que la OTAN no podía
defender a los bálticos en caso de que
Rusia decidiera invadirles.
Mientras tanto, Rusia, que también está
molesta por las relaciones entre la OTAN
y Ucrania y por cómo se le ha
demonizado, según ellos dicen, en la
cumbre de Varsovia,
tampoco se queda quieta:
Aviones molestando a barcos de la
OTAN en el báltico, movimientos
militares en su lado de la frontera y la
hipermilitarización de Kaliningrado, un
tema que da para vídeo propio. -"Los
misiles desplazados por Rusia a la
región de Kaliningrado inquietan a
Lituania y Polonia." Son sólo algunos de
los movimientos que están haciendo que
en Bruselas se muerdan las uñas.
-"La Unión Soviética está dispuesta a amnistiar
a un submarino desobediente. -¿La
Unión Soviética? ¿No se habían separado? - eso es lo que queríamos que ustedes
pensarán hahaha...
Tan nerviosos se están poniendo en
Bruselas qué a principios de este año
un general británico ligado a la OTAN
publicó un libro con un título tan
devastador como "2017 la Guerra con Rusia",
en el que incluso da una fecha exacta de
una invasión rusa sobre los bálticos.
Para ello, ha imaginado un escenario
plausible para el próximo año en el
que la organización se encuentra con
problemas de financiación,
-"Lo difícil de echarse un farol es saber
cuándo hay que dejarlo", y de capacidades
para ayudar a los bálticos en esa
invasión ya no tan sorpresa. Y éste
escenario en concreto se vuelve cada vez
más real
cada vez que un candidato a la
presidencia de los Estados Unidos
menciona a Rusia.
En efecto, Trump también tiene su parte
del pastel en todo esto. El candidato
republicano
últimamente ha soltado perlas tan
brillantes como que abandonaría la OTAN
si los demás países no incrementan sus
presupuestos militares, que no ayudaría
a los bálticos en caso de invasión
rusa y que Crimea está mucho mejor bajo
el control de Putin.
Con invasiones y conflictos armados a la
vista por ambas partes, como veis
las diferencias existentes entre la
Guerra Fría del siglo pasado y la
situación actual no son demasiadas. Me
gustaría decir que no hay nada escrito
sobre a dónde va a llevar todo esto,
pero ya lo hay.
Y,á vosotros, ¿qué os parece? ¿Creéis que
estamos ante una nueva Guerra Fría o en
una nueva Guerra Fría? y ¿A dónde nos va
a llevar esta escalada de tensión, tan
innecesaria, en la que nos estamos
metiendo? Espero vuestros comentarios
y si os ha gustado el video darle a like
y suscribimos al canal que es gratis.